look at you movie star what's going on
with that Tony hopeful well first of all
we have the premiere last night and I
apologize it from a little little rusty
here I've Lou in it we have been had a
little after party at his house and uh I
need a little water a little at he'll
look working a little hangover here but
i but i'm gonna i'm going to power
through it because I because I love you
Dan and I'm happy to be on the show who
was the most famous person at the party
last night well besides bend evil yeah I
don't know if it gets bigger than him
but of God who came d put kekkai
Michelle Rodriguez deepika she's in the
movie michelle rodriguez was there
freaking the DJ cruise there's a lot of
people i don't want to bust people out
but there was there was a couple stars
there in the house for sure got a lot of
guys from the movie pretty much the
whole cast from the movie was there we
we had a great time it was get a great
turnout I mean I'm in your world now
dance movies it was a lot of fun how
many how much do people know about your
football career of those you work with
on the movie there's been diesel know
what kind of tight end you were you know
they're actors too so they they pretend
like it so then you know he comes up
here I it's the greatest idea of all
time so and and I don't know if we
really know knew who I was but at least
he was he was acting like you do it you
know it this almost didn't happen for me
because you know I Sun samac being here
and there i've done the cameos little
sitcom stuff like that i have a small
recurring role on on NCIS but not never
anything like this so last year I get
the I get an email saying come audition
for this movie called XXX and I know XXX
is Vin Diesel that's all that's of ice
cube you know Samuel Jackson and I I say
to myself you know no I'm not going to
do it I don't want to do it because I'm
kind of scared I got admitted you know
it's a little bit out of my league I
would think realized so I get a call the
next day I get a call next day from my
my manager named content
schwoz she's from yonkers new york and
got this accent and she didn't even say
hello to me I say hello if she goes are
you out of your f in mine and I'm like
what what do you wanna talk about it she
goes you get your ass down there and you
are kissing for this movie and I was
like she's Oh what do you got what do
you got to lose so she was exactly right
i was like you're right you're
absolutely right con i'm gonna go down
there and I auditioned it was like 10
people they're auditioning for the part
it was so I went in there had nothing to
lose and I got it obviously and you know
the rest is history as far as the movie
goes so a lot of fun is how do you deal
with this thing how do you deal when you
go on set and you're working with a guy
like like Adam Sandler you know what was
by the way I know Constance and it's
tough to say no to Constance the most
humbling moment I've had in my
broadcasting career was when I was on
stage with nicole kidman and Jennifer
Aniston with Sandler and Dave Matthews
in the audience watching me as i'm doing
this part of the movie and i had an
out-of-body experience yet at one point
I'm thinking kidman and aniston are
probably looking at me saying what a
fraud they had no idea who I was and I'm
thinking how can I just get through this
and not embarrass myself but that was
that was one of those moments where i
had to ad-lib the entire scene and it
there was nothing in the script so
Sandler goes Danny ad lib and it was a
damn contests and and I'm going oh my
god I kidman staring at me like do you
know are you supposed to be doing this
like are you really an actor and then I
so I had that moment where I was I was
terrified petrified but that was the
only moment because usually Sandler
movie sets or pretty lacks pretty pretty
akula I think for me gah so Tony NFL on
CBS studio analyst that's his day job
also you play basketball in college I
don't know if it's the older you get the
better you were so when somebody says
hey what kind of basketball player were
you give us a sense of how good you were
at Cal I would have I was one of the
best players ever in the passion
average 30 points a game it was easy no
no I think here's my thing people always
ask me that question do you think you
could have played in NBA um and if you
look at my staff as far as how many
points I average per game if you look it
up right now it's not designed
impressive it's like it'll say six or
seven points a game but I will tell you
this I played football and I always
showed up to basketball season way deep
into the season pretty much right it's
almost at the beginning of a pat of
league play a month and a half has
already gone by they these guys have
been preparing so I'd get up I was total
meathead at the beginning of my process
in basketball my appearance on the
basketball team so I just got there get
rebounds try to play defense and usually
play around zero I mean well around one
two three minutes a game than the coach
would yank me why I get in shape get my
shot back around stuff but that counts
as games but by the end of every season
I always ended up starting I always
started the last six seven games and as
a starter I averaged around 17 points
again you go look it up so I always tell
myself I know I if I would have devoted
everything the basketball i think i
would have been a pretty good one maybe
maybe had a chance to go to the NBA I
like to think I could have done it but
you know obviously not as good as
football I knew football was was a
little bit more a better future for me
but I love playing about sweet 16 cab
we're gonna have a reunion of our sweet
16 team we lost against Dean Smith and
Vince Carter and Antoine Jamison in the
sweet 16 but definitely hope dreams you
know hoops me hoops isn't was my thing
but who is the best player you faced um
i guess it turns of NBA stardom that
went on to be an NBA start probably that
team right there Vince Vince Carter was
was Antoine Jamison voting us that North
Carolina team act is the coolest
compliment I ever got about me and
basketball was before that game we
played against the North Carolina Tar
Heels Dean Smith legendary Dean Smith I
was on a run like I said I had been
starting the last six games i'm
averaging around you know 16 17 points
I'm the guy on our team and I'm
stretching in the hall
way by myself before the game starts and
down walks Dean Smith by himself so it's
just him and I in the hallway and he
comes up and he says hey I'm being Smith
nice to meet you and I go nice to meet
you coach and he goes I just want you to
know and at this point I had already
declared to go to the NFL is going to
play in the NFL he goes I just want you
to know that you're a hell of a
basketball player and if you wanted to
you could play in the NBA and I was like
oh being Smith telling me that I could
plant in ba how cool is that and then he
goes as good luck tonight and he walks
away and then he turns around he goes
hey I got something special for you
tonight and he gives me like a little
wink and keeps walking what it was we
get on the court that night and instead
of playing man the man like they had
always done and which I can operate
because I'm kind of shortened to play
power forward or three at being 64 of he
went to a 2-3 zone with Antoine Jameson
this big seven-foot to russian guy in
the middle Kent members name I think uh
god I can't remember the other guy went
to the NBA the other 68 guy so I had
these every time I caught the ball I had
these trees around me and I would have
to kick it back out all right so I guy
scores four points in that game and we
lost by I think only you know six points
for six points but uh but yet the great
Dean Smith has a game plan against me
and Jamie the best cop I ever had one of
us calm has ever had my life so it's fun
could you play this weekend if you
wanted to um what do you mean like go to
the bars and click on my football yeah
yeah yeah Mike third down uh I'm sorry
you know then I think I could I I
believe with a competitive again I could
I could go out there and go and I always
look at these games I'm like look at
this big big tight in that they have
here athletic I why don't they just have
them go five yards and turn around and
throw them the ball for the first down
because I always felt like that's that
subject that any good tiding could do
most coaches don't call that place so
yes I think I could go out there I could
give you a good solid
15 plays third down I'm gonna catch the
ball I'm not gonna try to make a move
and I would tell the defense don't
tackle me so I'm gonna go down as I said
which quarterback would you want this
weekend now yeah I got to take out Matt
Ryan because you're going to play the
hometown so thank you okay so mark you
can play with Rogers Brady or bend
mm-hmm God oh that what I've never had
that courts like you know which which
supermodel is did you like to hang out
with you know I did I would if you look
at right now the way Aaron Rodgers
display knees he's the hottest
quarterback right now out of all these
guys among hot quarter but you know
Brady luscious tight in he does I I
gotta go with uh I gotta go with Aaron
Rodgers right now just because when the
play breaks that I used to love it when
the plate broke down when the
quarterback was back to his grandmas
because that's like basketball it's like
I got to get open on the omelet I got
this whole feel to play with and you
know as my basketball background was you
know it's smaller small on a battle of
bored you got to get opened as a plain
man to man and you can do like a little
elk I always felt like that was that was
fun for me I caught a lot of balls when
the quarterback let's cram because i was
like i can get open so a guy like Aaron
Rodgers that would play right into what
what I like to do and the way he's
playing right now it's it's easing in
that ball I've seen this before when
they came in and beat us in 2010 I was
with the Falcons and he got on one of
these rolls right they went won the
Super Bowl he looks just like that it's
deja vu and that's why they're so
dangerous right now he's Tony Gonzalez
you can shame on CBS part of their NFL
coverage and also the new movie is XXX
the return of xander cage it hits
theaters today great to catch up with
you Tony and thanks for joining us
thanks really appreciate like Tony
Gonzalez little banged up from a post
premiere party at least you admitted it
with Vin Diesel I like how we were going
to have him on a half hour earlier I
think he was shaken some cobwebs out
there the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
you